support booth University in the
production of more videos by visiting
the link in the description below where
you'll find more details thank you and
enjoy okay so so far I've kind of
mentioned Adams here and there but I
haven't really talked about what they
are or how he came up with them and
things like that
so we're going to start things off by
talking about Dalton's atomic theory and
billiard ball model which he started in
1808 so Dalton of course is John Dalton
we recently mentioned him when we talked
about the LOB portions so when Dalton
came up with this idea about atomic
theory basically he was trying to come
up with trying to explain what makes up
matter and so he came up with these
postulates which were basically
statements that he believed to be true
about what makes up matter okay
specifically these atoms and one thing I
want you to notice is that I've kind of
had them here as bullet points I didn't
number them and the reason why I did
that is because I've seen them in
different orders so I don't really know
what the correct or universally accepted
way of numbering them is and also
sometimes they're not just for sometimes
I see a minus for sometimes people write
them as five different postulates so you
might see different things and I kind of
just went with four bullet points here
okay
just as a disclaimer so the first thing
that he said was that all matter
consists of tiny indivisible particles
called atoms
okay so tiny indivisible particles
called atoms
so indivisible means that you cannot
break them right so this is the idea
that matter cannot be created or cannot
be destroyed right or created so matter
cannot be destroyed alright these atoms
cannot be destroyed and of course or
created and that of course is the law of
mass conservation right law of
s conservation or the conservation of
mass so that statement and that law kind
of go ahead and end next thing we said
was the atoms of the same element are
identical in mass and other properties
okay so atoms of the same element so as
long as you have atoms of a particular
element all of those atoms of that
element will have identical mass and
properties okay the properties also
those set atoms of a particular element
are going to be different from the atoms
of other elements so basically this is
kind of saying that atoms of an element
are unique right so atoms of an element
are unique period I mean not really
period the idea is that that's kind of
what this statement is saying right but
particularly in this way anyway next
postulate atoms of an element can
chemically combined with atoms of other
elements in specific small whole number
ratios to form different chemical
compounds so this is this postulate is
kind of like it's kind of a statement it
basically wraps up the two of the matter
laws right the law of definite
composition definite composition and the
law of multiple proportions right gotta
have those small whole number ratios of
elements of an atoms to another and you
can have two two different elements
combining in more than just one way
right the last thing that he said was
that atoms are recombined in chemical
reactions and chemical reactions as
opposed to nuclear reactions that's a
detail that we'll talk more about later
but atoms were recombining chemical
reactions he says that atoms of an
element are not converted into atoms of
a different elements so if you have
atoms of an element they cannot be
converted into atoms of a different
element so those were his postulates and
based on those postulates he came up
what was called a billiard ball model
and billiard balls of course if you guys
have played pool or billiards that some
people call it um this is basically a
pool table rack right if you have a
little triangle thing anyway he thought
that atoms were kind of like billiard
balls that if you if you and you see a
billiard ball but it's contained
basically all of one material it's like
that really really hard plastic that is
that was just like cracking um he
thought that atoms were kind of like
that thought they were just like all one
material and from um from element to
element the atoms differed so that's
kind of what started things off this is
his atomic theory and not very many
people believed him at first but over
time people kind of began to grow into
this and and sort of try to figure out
more about atoms and develop atomic
theory so I hope that video is helpful
as a good introduction to atomic theory
and thank you for watching if found that
video helpful be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more content also follow
move university on the different social
media links in the description below
thank you and happy studying